>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> John Van Oudenaren: My
name is John Van Oudenaren.
I'm the acting interim director
of the Kluge Center here
at the Library of Congress.
Welcome to all of you and
welcome to our speakers.
Thank you to our speakers.
This is an experiment
cafe -- Kluge Cafe series.
This is the first time
we're doing this.
And so we're actually very
interested in getting feedback
from the -- from the
participants and the speakers
as well as how well this works.
I'll say a little bit about
the background to this
as I understood it because I was
sort of vaguely involved in some
of the discussions early
on about this series.
I think idea is to give our fellows
a chance to present their work
in a more informal setting, relieve
them a little bit of the burden
of doing a big formal
talk, although they may --
some of them may still want to
do that, and we'll still do that.
But this is a chance to sort
of present their work sitting
down as opposed to
standing at this lectern.
It's a chance -- it's
a -- the idea is
to foster interaction
amongst scholars.
Serendipity look for
unexpected thoughts and insights
that might come from having
people together on the platform.
So it is, as I said, an experiment
and we're looking forward
to seeing how it works.
Let me just briefly introduce
the speakers, the participants,
and then get out of the way.
We have Ascension Mazuela-Anguita
from Spain, who is going to work --
introduce you to her project on
Alan Lomax's fieldwork in Spain.
Chet Van Duzer, I'm proceeding
from right to the left,
or my right to your left, Chet Van
Duzer who is the 2016 Mellon Fellow
at the Kluge Center
and he is working
on the Ptolemaic World is Not
Enough annotation for education
in the Princeton copy of
Ptolemy's Geography 1525.
And then to his left Margarita
Karnysheva, who is writing
about researching and writing
about a misinterpreted mission,
American Intervention
in Siberia 1918 to 1920.
Many of you must -- might know
the great George Kennan work
on this area and Richard Allman
[assumed spelling] worked
in this area so she's actually
adding new insights into this.
And then the missing chair there is
for Chelsea Stieber, who will arrive
in a few minutes we hope.
And she's working on writing for
Haiti regionalism in the creation
of modern Haitian literature,
1890 to 1940.
So those are the topics.
I spent a little time trying
to think of a common theme
that wove them altogether
and I just sort of gave up.
I thought it would be best to let
the scholars tell what they're doing
and we'll see what emerges.
So with that I will get out of the
way and turn it over to our fellows.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ascension Mazuela-Anguita:
Thank you.
It is a great honor to have
spent eight months doing research
at the Alan Lomax Fellow
at the Kluge Center [inaudible]
intellectually stimulating
utmost fear.
I would like to express my
appreciation to the Kluge staff
and to the Kluge fellows
for [inaudible]
and insightful discussion.
I am so grateful to Abby
Porter [assumed spelling]
from the [inaudible] for
her interest in my project.
I cannot thank enough
the daily assistance
of the American Folk Life Center's
excellent staff, and especially
of [inaudible] of the
Alan Lomax collection.
Let's start with music.
[ Inaudible ]
[ Singing ]
This is one of the almost 1500
folksongs recorded by Alan Lomax
in Spain between 1952
and January 1953.
The material resource of his
journey, which are preserved
at the American Folk Life Center,
include music on magnetic tape,
but also photographs, [inaudible],
invoices, annotated maps, letters,
diaries, and even the manuscript
of part of a book for publication.
Why did Lomax undertake
field working in Spain?
Columbia Records had
commission [inaudible]
to bring together a series
of folk music albums,
each of which would be
devoted to a country or region.
One of the albums would
be dedicated to Spain.
Lomax wrote [inaudible]
musician and writer,
director of the British
Council in Spain asking guidance
to help him find a
Spanish folklorist
with experience in field recording.
On this light we can see
[inaudible] indicating
that Spanish ethnic
musicologists continue
to write the music down by hand.
Given the possibility of
finding a collaborator
with the required equipment and
experience, Lomax, who was living
in Paris at that moment, decided
to attend the attend the
Folklore [inaudible] Festival
to be celebrated in
[inaudible] in June 1952
as it would be a good
opportunity for networking.
The coordinator of the
festival was [inaudible],
a [inaudible] musicologist who
had been appointed director
of the folklore division
of the former Spanish
Institute of Musicology.
According to Lomax, when Schneider
[assumed spelling] learned
about his project he stated that
he would personally see to it
that no Spanish musicologist
would help him.
It was this encounter that
made Lomax promise himself
that he would record in Spain.
The main source of funding
was the BBC in London,
which was planning a series
of broadcasts in Spain.
Lomax offered to provide them with
recordings if they finance his trip
and that of his British
assistant, [inaudible].
The lack of cooperation from
the Spanish musicologist
to whom Lomax referred leaves us to
wonder how he succeeded [inaudible]
that allowed him to
complete his project.
It is also worth considering how his
approach to fieldwork defers to that
of [inaudible] working in
Spain at the same time.
The aim of my visit was
to answer these questions
by analyzing the documents from
Lomax's Spain trip [inaudible]
from oral history and
technological tools.
These materials offer
a unique opportunity
to approach the political situation
and the Francoist dictatorship,
the poverty of the country, and the
moral constrictions faced by women
through the eyes of
Lomax and [inaudible].
Digital tools has been used in
order to establish connections
between the songs recorded by
Lomax and other collections
of Spanish traditional music
compiled around the same time,
such as [inaudible] at the
Spanish National Research Council
in Barcelona.
The Barcelona collection is
primarily made up of more
than 20,000 folksongs copied on
paper and collected throughout Spain
between 1944 and 1960, most of them
through the so-called folkloric
missions and competitions organized
by the former Spanish
Institute of Musicology.
Since 2011 I have been involved
in the project to digitize
and catalogue the Barcelona
collection
in an open access database.
As the first stage of my research
at the Library of Congress,
I have incorporated the details
provided by the Lomax collection
into the same database,
cataloging information
on all the places visited by
Lomax in Spain and all the songs
and people recorded there, including
his [inaudible] on the Association
for Cultural Equity Online Archive.
The material was catalogued
by listening to the songs
and consulting Lomax's notes
on the [inaudible] boxes along
with his diaries and notebooks.
Some of the songs were broadcast
into series of programs by the BBC.
The song commentaries were
cited in the database as well
as the notes included in the
albums that were published
by Lomax or edited later.
I also analyze catalogue
and transcribe documents
such as field notebooks,
annotated maps, letters,
and diaries connecting
them to the music, people,
and locations to which they
refer, and including links
to the corresponding [inaudible]
on the Library of Congress website.
Lomax's writings offer contradictory
details regarding his itinerary
and the dates of the
recording sessions.
Accounting records, such as
those related to accommodation
or car repair, have been
particularly useful here
as they provide accurate evidence
of Lomax's itinerary and dates.
The state has prepared the materials
for analysis and comparison.
It is now possible to identify
concordances between this collection
and the one in Barcelona.
Mutual enrichment between
collection can first be achieved
through these digital tool.
As part of the second stage,
I have been using the database
as a research tool
for interpreting data
and preparing an academic
monograph on Lomax's [inaudible]
in the cultural context
of mid-20th century Spain.
At the same time, through
the social networks
to which the database is
connected, Lomax's contribution
to Spanish traditional
music can be better known
and appreciated by
a general audience.
In order to provide a different
approach, both to the database
and to the Lomax Spanish
collect at the library,
I have created a story map
which presents Lomax's
itinerary connecting each town
to the [inaudible] sample of an
example of the music recorded there.
These are also connected to
[inaudible] image belonging
to the Lomax collection
and to a link
to the complete information
concerning
that location on the database.
This application was intended
to make data more visual
and accessible not only
to researchers but also
to our brother audience outside the
[inaudible] purely academic context.
Analyzing references
distributed in a variety
of documental sources allows us
to compose Lomax's [inaudible]
and to understand his itinerary.
Lomax explained what he named
the Spanish [inaudible].
A recognized person provided
him with a business card,
which included a brief
note as a type of letter
of recommendation asking
another person
to assist Lomax in his project.
I will mention a few
examples of Lomax's contacts.
We already mentioned [inaudible]
Festival invited Lomax to his house
in Madrid and provided him with
tape at the end of his journey.
He [inaudible] in honor of
the virgin, Lomax would drive
to the area to record their music
following [inaudible] suggestions.
Through the database it is
possible to find concordances
between Lomax's recordings
of this group
and the [inaudible] years before as
part of the Barcelona collection.
[ Speaking Foreign Language ]
[ Singing ]
Another international figure
who attended the Panama Festival was
[inaudible] actually a musicologist.
Subsequently, Lomax
visited him in [inaudible]
and recorded [inaudible]
in his company.
[Inaudible] explained to Lomax some
aspects of the political situation
in Spain, as well as the
origin of folk groups
from different Spanish regions that
participated in the Panama Festival.
Most of them formed part of
various government initiatives.
Lomax thought that folklore was
something that lives, changes,
especially in the country,
this is contrasted
with the official folklore
music of Spain from that period.
In Madrid Lomax studies
connection with researchers
who were compiling music
for the Spanish Institute
of Musicology, such as [inaudible].
The later, for instance, [inaudible]
the north of Spain and planned
to worked with Lomax in both
the south of Spain and Morocco.
[Inaudible], who told Lomax that
the music of this remote village
in the [inaudible] was of
interest for its antiquity.
Consequently, Lomax visited this
place where he recorded music
in the house of this man.
[Inaudible] had visited the
same village six years before
and had transcribed some
of the pieces performed
by the same informant.
[ Singing ]
[ Music ]
In Madrid Lomax also had a meeting
with the [inaudible] in October.
His [inaudible] influenced
Lomax's subsequent itinerary
in the north of Spain.
For example, [inaudible]
friend and history professor
at [inaudible] University
[inaudible] Lomax counseling all
his commitments.
According to Lomax, the professor
had friends throughout that region
and only needed a phone call to
provide him with [inaudible].
After leaving Spain Lomax returned
to Paris and in April moved
to London where he worked on
the revision of the recordings
in close collaboration
with [inaudible],
an [inaudible] Spanish
musicologist who worked for the BBC.
The excerpt on the slide suggests
that [inaudible] propose Lomax
for the BBC for the [inaudible]
to record music in Spain.
Lomax and [inaudible] joined book
publication which was not brought
to completion probably due
to [inaudible] death in 1955.
[Inaudible] also provides an
[inaudible] between Lomax's work
in Spain and the first systematic
recordings of Spanish folk music,
which were [inaudible] between
July 1932 and January 1933
by [inaudible], U.S. citizens
of [inaudible] origin.
The context of these
recordings was the center
for history [inaudible] in Madrid.
[Inaudible] was the
person responsible
for the folklore division
of this institution
and assisted [inaudible]
in his field work.
It is remarkable that
two researchers
from the United States carried
out field recordings in Spain
at a 20 year interval in
such contrasting political
and cultural situations,
that this --
the second republic
and the dictatorship.
These [inaudible] in differences
with regards to contacts
and institutional support.
Lomax's network of contacts in
Spain included musicologists,
but [inaudible] procession of
people such as artists, journalists,
anthropologists, and even people
who he have just met on his arrival
in a town and acted
as spontaneous guides.
He had [inaudible] Lomax's
assistant, in this journey commented
that she never really knew how he
got hold of all the people he did.
Lomax's documents contain
constant references to [inaudible]
and reflect the important
role that she played
in helping Spanish women open up for
the recordings and talk about topics
that they would never have
discussed with [inaudible].
A part of my research consisted
of analyzing how women,
from their own spaces,
contributing to setting --
contributed to setting
up this collection.
[Inaudible] writing are scattered
among Lomax's papers so that
at first they could be confused
with text written by Lomax himself.
They begin with a description
of [inaudible] arrival
in Barcelona Airport in August
1952, and an encounter with Lomax.
They also contain comments on her
experiences through her journey,
her role in the recording
process, and her feelings.
These memoirs demonstrate her
connections with Spanish women.
For instance, learning to dance
with young girls or trying
on traditional women's costumes.
She also explained her
experience when Lomax left her
to record a group of young
girls on her own and even wrote
that Spanish women were the
nicest people she had ever met.
[Inaudible] was also
skilled at talking with men.
For example, when Lomax reported
on his field work in the north
of Spain he wrote that while
he recorded a young man told
[inaudible] some of the things
[inaudible] wouldn't have told him
about the sex life in the area.
[Inaudible] memoirs are very rich
in comments on the particularities
of Spanish family culture.
To give an example,
26 year old widow
from the [inaudible]
region explained to her
that before marrying women used
to have a boyfriend for more
than 10 years and that when
a husband died his wife had
to wear black clothes forever.
Spanish women talk
about their lives,
but also sang songs
related to their customs.
[ Music ]
Lomax showed a special interest in
Spanish women's lives and explained
that in his worldwide field work
he found feature of song and dance
that are specific to women.
When he recorded [inaudible] he
always asked the female singer
to hold a child in her arms.
Women played an important role
in the oral transmission
of music in Spain.
The clear [inaudible] of the
Barcelona collection were women
and they have learned the
songs from their mothers
or grandmothers or from other girls.
To conclude, the material results
of Lomax's Spain trip can only
barely reflect the deep impact
that his visit must have
had on the habitants
of the small villages
where he recorded.
His amazing legacy can
complement other collections
of Spanish folk music compiled
on paper in the same period.
Lomax's itinerary reflects
concordances
with the fieldwork carried
out by Spanish researchers
whose [inaudible] from part
of the Barcelona collection.
However, these concordances
have a very limited scope.
This is probably due to
the [inaudible] of people
who follow Lomax's contact
network to his limited relationship
with Spanish musicologists and
to his concept of folklore.
The approach to the
[inaudible] and singing of women
through the otherness of
Lomax and [inaudible] suggest
that oral tradition is a key
question that must be asked
to challenge the loss of women's
voices in historical accounts
and to place women on
the map of music history.
The accessibility of this collection
[inaudible] easily researchable
and interactive platform
through the database
and the map application will allow
researchers [inaudible] school
teachers, folk music performance,
and the community in general to use
and enjoy this magnificent
collection increasing a
sociological impact.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Chet Van Duzer: Hello.
Thank you all for coming.
Changing subjects a little bit,
although Ascension did show an
annotated map, a map annotated
by Lomax, so we have that
commonality working for us.
I'll be talking to
you this afternoon
about an extraordinary book,
a copy of Ptolemy's Geography,
the 1525 edition which is held by
Princeton in the university library.
And it is very, very
heavily annotated,
has many handwritten
annotations on it as you'll see.
Ptolemy's Geography, when it was
rediscovered in Byzantium about --
in about 1300, and then spread
across Europe in the 14th
and 15th century in both a
manuscript and printed editions,
it became the most
important geographical text
of the European renaissance.
And on the one hand, there was
a great enthusiasm for the work.
It was reproduced in
many manuscripts
and a great abundance
of printed editions.
But on the other hand, there was
a dissatisfaction with the work,
specifically as regards the fact
that it's a mathematical geography.
It's not very descriptive at all.
The work consists of text that gives
instructions on how to make maps
and a database of 8000 locations
with their latitudes and longitudes.
So very little in the
way of description.
And so the work came to be
supplemented in various ways.
And one of those ways was
annotation, as we see here.
So here's the Ptolemaic
map of Spain in the book,
and in case you can't see it
immediately, all of the text
that I've highlighted
is handwritten,
supplementary, descriptive
information.
So it's really an extraordinary
book.
Looking at a few other
maps from this book.
Here's the Ptolemaic world map.
And as you can see, it's surrounded
by handwritten supplementary texts.
The texts are not only on
the maps themselves but also
on black pages following the maps.
The annotator was that enthusiastic
and he had so much to say
that he also wrote
on following pages.
The text, as I said, was printed --
this edition was printed in 1525.
The annotations were
composed in 1527.
At one point the annotators
refers to a historical event
as having taken place last summer,
and that event took place in 1526.
I want to point out here, this is
something I'll return to later,
that what Princeton has
is really half the book.
So we can see a visible
difference in the paper
in the two parts of the book here.
And what have is the end of the text
block on the left and the beginning
of the maps on the right.
So at some point in the book's
history a dealer had these
annotated maps.
He realized that in order
to get the full value
out of selling the book
it had to be complete.
So he took the text
from another copy
and bound it together with the maps.
So we have in the Princeton
copy the annotated maps
with unannotated text
from a different copy.
So what does all this text say?
Well, it's -- he's
adding very substantial
and very detailed descriptive text
to Ptolemy's basically mathematical
description of the world.
So just to look at a few examples.
On the third map of Africa,
looking at this text, add, he says,
and that's an instruction to the
student, these annotations were made
for a student, which is one of
the most interesting aspects,
add right in this book that
the map above is defective,
for there where I put this
sign, the one I've circled,
is the Aphroditopolites nome and a
landlocked metropolis between which
and Crocodilopolis,
towards the Nile,
there was a Lake Mirios
about which below.
And then on the map
he places that sign
to the location where
this text applies.
Looking at another example, the
Ptolemaic fourth map of Asia,
looking at the text
in the left margin.
He says, not far from Tripoli there
is a field that Strabo calls Marca
in which Posidonius says
a dead dragon was seen.
It covered half an acre, and was
so thick that men mounted on horses
on either side could
not see each other.
Its mouth was large enough to
receive a man riding a horse,
and each scale of its skin
was larger than a shield.
So this really couldn't be any
more different from Ptolemy's text,
this long list of 8000 places with
their latitudes and longitudes.
He's giving a historical,
descriptive information,
including about, if you would
say, the animals or monsters
that were thought to live
in a particular region.
Looking at the Ptolemaic
map of Spain.
Again in the left margin, he says,
there is great confusion among
different authors regarding the name
of the promontory in
Spain that faces west.
And he goes on to discuss
in considerable detail the different
opinions regarding the name
of this promontory of Ptolemy, Mela,
Pliny, Solinus, Aelian, and Strabo.
So he's very engaged with
classical literature,
and we'll see more
evidence of that later.
The map of the Atlantic
and the New World.
Again, we can see very
heavy annotation.
And these annotations are some of
the most interesting in the book.
He talks -- he's talking about
the discovery of the New World
and the discovery of the route
from Europe around Africa to Asia.
And what he says is that
these are not new discoveries,
that both of these things, the
New World and the route to Asia
around Africa, had been
discovered in antiquity.
And so he makes little of the recent
Spanish and Portuguese discoveries.
On the preceding page, that is
the page just before this map
of the New World, he writes,
remark, as I often said,
that neither this route to the
west, nor that of the Portuguese
around the tip of Africa, is
new, but had already been done
by other ancients, then abandoned,
and now finally in our times taken
up again, as is clear from
Aristotle, a most celebrated witness
and a noble author for
increasing one's confidence.
And on the map himself he
says, along these same lines,
we will venture, based on
the excerpts from Aristotle
that I transcribed below,
that the men and women found
in this new land were Carthaginians
by origin, and that afterwards,
left alone and deprived of
communication with other peoples,
they became savages and gradually
lost their customs and rites
and the use of clothing
through long desuetude.
So this question is of where the
peoples of the New World came from?
If all people were
descended from Adam and Eve
and Columbus was the first
to reach the New World,
where did the people
living there come from?
And what he's saying is that
they were Carthaginians.
That they're Carthaginians,
this [inaudible] work claimed
that Carthaginian sailors
encountered a large land mass
in the Atlantic, and
what he was concluding is
that that was how the
New World was peopled.
The annotator had a
strong character.
He -- as we saw, he is very
content to disagree with Ptolemy.
He also did not hesitate to
voice was rather strong opinions
about the peoples who lived
in the maps in Ptolemy.
So if we look at the modern map
of France, he has drawn a banner
across the top which says, this
province produces a great number
of chicken farmers,
innkeepers, cooks, flute-players,
gamblers, drunkards, and fools.
[ Laughter ]
The modern map of Spain.
He says here, the best thing for
one's financial affairs is not
to take a loan from a
Catalan merchant [laughter].
And there are similar statements
on a number of the maps.
They're all negative except for
one, which is -- I'll mention later,
he -- across one of the
maps of Italy he says
that heroic virtue is
innate to Italian blood.
Guess where he was from [laughter]?
So some of -- not all of
the maps are annotated.
We saw that a number of them are
very, very heavily annotated.
Some of them have no
annotations at all.
And we can't be certain because --
whether that was because
the annotator was not
so interested in those regions.
It's also possible that he
just didn't finish the program
of annotation he had in mind.
But the fact, I'm inclined to
think that we can read something
into the fact that
they're not annotated,
because if they had been priorities
for him he would have
come to them sooner.
So the Ptolemaic map of Taprobana.
There was an abundance
of classical material
that he could've added
to the map here.
He did not.
And I take this as evidence
that his real interest was
in the Mediterranean Basin,
which was where the classical
civilizations of Greece
and Rome were most active.
The modern map of the Holy
Land has no annotations.
I think that's quite surprising
in 16th century Europe.
So, again, his interest
was classical antiquity,
not religious history.
The modern map of Southern Africa.
Another -- from another annotator we
might have expected some text here
about Portuguese voyages
around Africa.
As we saw, he thought little of
those voyages so it's not surprising
that he makes no remark here.
Looking at a few of the
sources of the annotations.
One of his most -- the
book that he had to resort
to most frequently was Caelius
Rhodiginus' Antiquarum Lectionum
Libri IVI books.
It's basically an encyclopedia.
It's a very poorly organized
encyclopedia with quotations
from classical authors on an
enormous variety of subjects.
And when I go through the
annotations and I find
that he's citing a classical author,
I have to check whether he's
citing the author directly
or citing the classical author
by way of this book for example.
A very similar book in terms of
its nature that is consisting
of enormous masses of quotations
from classical authors is this book
by Sabelico, another work
of encyclopedic nature.
This is the title page of
the edition of Pomponius Mela
with annotations by the
Swiss scholar Vadianus.
This was another of
his favorite sources.
And he makes use not
only of Pomponius Mela,
the Roman geographer, but also
Vadianus' commentary on Mela.
And Giovanni Pontano's Dialogi,
that's the source of some
of his insulting comments about
the peoples of various regions.
So he's a humanist scholar.
He doesn't just take an
insult he heard on the street.
He has a source, a classical -- a
literary source for his insults.
The care spent on the
annotations, one of the nice things
about this project is that
the annotations were written
by a scribe, which is
somewhat surprising.
It has the great benefit of making
most of the text pretty legible.
And just to compare the hand
in which these annotations
were written, that is the hand
of a scribe, with those in another
annotated Ptolemy that's a little
bit more typical, we see
here the difficult hand
of a scholar's annotation in
a different copy of Ptolemy,
much more difficult to read.
So the mere fact that a scribe
was hired to write these text
into this copy of the
book bespeaks a project
with a lot of money to play with.
Modern map of eastern India.
Looking at the text on the
following page the annotator says,
in addition to what was said on
the four other maps of India,
I think it is here worth adding a
few words regarding the fertility
of that land.
My point here is that he's
referring to the text he wrote
on the other four maps of India.
It's a whole planned
program of annotations.
It's not just casual remarks that
he made as they occurred to him.
The Ptolemaic world map
that I showed earlier.
Tremendous care was devoted
to the planning and layout
of the annotations on this page.
At the top and bottom we
have symmetrical quotations
from Vitruvius about the
inhabitants of the northern
and southern parts of the world.
We have these triangular boxes
at the corners of the map.
It's no accident that the text
fits in those triangles so neatly.
He has a little title to
the annotations that run
down the left and right margins.
At the left we have
on the Hyperboreans.
On the right on the Antipodes.
And I want to point out that the
text is perfectly symmetrical.
So it runs down the margins
and then into the lower margins
and it ends at symmetrical points.
And this, again, was -- it
didn't happen by accident.
It was all very carefully planned.
So we're talking about a project to
which very substantial resources,
both of time and money,
were devoted.
The purpose of the
annotations, as I mentioned,
these annotations are unusual in
that they were made for a student.
So what we have in this book is a
program of geographical education
in the early 16th century.
It's really quite extraordinary.
And I want to look at
some of the evidence
that the annotations
were made for a student.
On the third map of Africa, in the
lower left, the annotator writes,
where I added the Nasamones,
who were missing,
so that you would know
the custom of this people.
So he's addressing the student.
And also in this annotation we see
an interest in teaching the student
about ethnography,
teaching the student
about the customs of
different peoples.
The Ptolemaic map of Greece, the
lower left, this I willingly written
so that you will know that these
provinces have many products suited
to the study of the inhabitants,
that is that are revealing
about the inhabitants.
So again, an interest
in ethnography,
an interest in the customs
of different peoples.
The eighth map of Europe.
About which also see
Book 1 of our Strabo,
to whom you should have recourse for
such things, rather than to others.
So he's giving the student advice
about which classical authors
to consult on which subjects.
Ptolemaic map of Asia Minor.
I've explained these things from
Alexander the Great here so that
by using them, you can
understand what Pliny says
in Book 5, chapter 29.
So he's expecting his student to
be very engaged with this material,
to be comparing information from
one source with that from another.
Ptolemaic map of Italy.
Of all the Alpine peoples, are
listed here by Pliny, but you,
speaking to the student, list
them with their modern names.
Write the modern names beside
the ancient ones, by conjecture.
So he's giving the
student an exercise.
Write out ancient names
from Ptolemy,
place beside them your best guesses
as to their modern equivalents.
Some material on the back of the
modern map of the British Isles.
For since I once crossed over
to Britain in order to get
to know the English customs and
pursuits, it would be unworthy,
if I did not add something
to this map regarding the
hospitality of that people.
So first of all, this indicates
some of the annotator's travels.
It also, again, reflects
the annotator's interest
in the customs of different people.
So how does this work?
How does the educational program
in this work compare with that
in other 16th century
texts that were aimed
at imparting geographical education?
Well, it turns out to be much more
sophisticated and thus was designed
for a much more advanced student.
So here's Peter Apian's
Cosmographicus liber of 1524.
There's a one-page description
of Africa in this work.
The annotator could easily write
one page about a river in Asia.
So he's offering a student a
much higher level of detail.
There's a long list of place names
with their latitudes and longitudes.
So this is exactly the sort
of mathematical geography
that one would get
from Ptolemy himself.
So the book is not adding
much for the student.
Johannes Honter's Rudimento
cosmographica.
One of the sentences is a list of
the most important cities of Poland.
Well, that's wonderful
but it's not much detail.
It's not any analysis.
So, again, I mean, and what Ptolemy
was basically offering was a list
of the places in Poland.
Here we have a list of
classical place names
with their modern equivalent,
that is a commonality
between contemporary graphical
text and the annotations.
So what can we conclude
about the annotator?
He was Italian.
He uses mostly Italian sources.
He occasionally uses an
Italian word in his Latin.
The banner, as I mentioned before,
across one map of Italy read,
heroic virtue is inherent
in Italian blood.
He traveled widely.
He visited the Hungarian court for
commerce, he mentions at one point.
He visited Augsburg.
He traveled to England
and he was familiar
with English ecclesiastical
writers and seems
to have visited the
shrine of Thomas Becket.
It's also possible that
he traveled in Greece.
I'm not entirely certain about that.
And his overriding interest was
in European classical antiquity.
The maps of Asia are
lightly annotated.
The modern maps are
There's no annotation of the map
of the Holy Land, as
I mentioned before.
He repeatedly argues against
the great antiquity of Egypt.
So if Egypt was more ancient than
Greece it would have more prestige,
so he argues that Egyptian
culture is not that old.
And he argues that recent
geographical discoveries merely
repeated the accomplishments
of the ancients.
So a few conclusions.
What exactly is this book?
It was intended for an advance
student of geography, clearly.
The annotations profess
an interest in ethnography
and more broadly demonstrate
the great richness
of classical geography.
The hiring of a scribe
and careful arrangement
of the texts indicate a
very expensive production.
Was this a copy made
for the student?
So was a scribe hired,
instead of the student
as he had been instructed writing
these texts in the book himself,
was a scribe hired
to do that for him?
Or was this perhaps a fair
copy for the annotator himself?
I'm not sure.
Finally, I mentioned before
that what Princeton had was
only really half the book.
It was the annotated maps without --
with a text block that
had no annotation.
And while I was doing this
research I was curious
about what might have
become of the other half
of the book, of the annotated text.
Surely an annotator who was
so enthusiastic would not have
left the text unannotated.
It seemed most likely that
the annotated text block
of the book had been just lost
over time, had been destroyed.
But through remarkable good
fortunate I managed to discover,
here again is showing the difference
between the two halves of the book,
I managed to discover the
text block of the 1525 edition
of Ptolemy's Geography in a private
collection Brussels annotated
by the same hand.
And the collector who owned the
book has now very generously sold it
to Princeton and so the two halves
of this extraordinary book
have now been rejoined
after considerable time spent apart.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Margarita Karnysheva:
Thanks everybody
for coming to listen to our talks.
Before I start my presentation I
would like to express my gratitude
to the Library of Congress
staff, in particular of course
to the Kluge Center people.
I also appreciate the
professionalism [inaudible]
divisions as well as
the European division
and the American Folk Life Center.
I also would like to say thank
you to Daniel [assumed spelling],
who provided very useful advice
and tips for my research.
And I am leaving in a week
so I'm sad a little bit
because I spent here nine
very fruitful months.
So thank you all again.
My research is on the American
expedition to Siberia between 1918
and 1920 when the Entente intervened
into the Russian Civil War.
This is another map, I am
following the previous presenters.
It's not easy to count exactly
how many countries participated,
but according to Winston
Churchill totaled 14 countries,
including the United States.
This is a military map, so the
blue color shows the [inaudible].
And the red color shows where allied
and [inaudible] forces were located.
The allies conducted [inaudible]
and counterinsurgency operations
against the Bolshevik Reds.
Since this controversial
[inaudible] is inseparably tied
to the Russian revolution
and the Civil War in Russia,
we have incalculable number
of publications on this topic.
Naturally the very fact of the
U.S. troops haven't been operated
in Russia, the fact of
[inaudible] interference
in the Russian Civil War
creates ample opportunities
for it being utilized
as a convenient tool
for anti-American propaganda
campaigns.
Unsurprisingly, the
narratives that have been formed
for 100 years mirrored all
the abrupt shifts in Soviet
and Russian American relations.
And, of course, due to the recent
rise of [inaudible] Americanism
in Russian, now these
narratives are often used
by the Russian propagandists.
The main goal of my research is
not the study of these events,
but investigation of historical
and political contexts in which
the main interpretation is both
in Russian and English where
written, as well as how ideological,
political, and social
affiliations of the numerous writers
of these events shape the narrative
-- the narratives they produced.
While doing my research I identified
the two dominating Russian language
narratives, which can be
conventionally named the red
and the white.
The red, or the Soviet
communist party narrative,
consists of two interpretations.
One is the [inaudible]
illusion created by the group
of Marxist historians
led by Pokrovsky,
who in 1919 himself actively
participated in the negotiations
on signing separate peace treaty
between Russia and Germany.
Being vehemently anti-British,
anti-French, and anti-Japanese,
this group asserted that the United
States has not recognized the
intervention and American
participation
in the real fighting was
actually very limited.
Even though they harshly
criticized President Wilson
for his [inaudible] imperialistic
and now colonial foreign
policy disguised
under democratic [inaudible],
I would say that this
narrative was rather favorable.
In the 1930's this
narrative was reconsidered due
to internal political struggle
in the Soviet leadership
and the rapidly changing
international situation
on the eve of the World War II.
Following the deterioration of
Soviet Japanese relations that led
to the civil [inaudible] wars,
the Soviet historians claimed
that they recognize that
the most active participant
of the [inaudible] intervention
has been imperial Japan
and Trotsky has been accused of
being a German and Japanese spy.
The beginning of the Cold War;
however, resulted in creation
of the narrative where America was
viewed as the organizer and sponsor
of the Entente intervention.
This narrative dominated
official Soviet historiography
up to the 1990's when
it was replaced
by the anti-communist
white narrative.
It is worth mentioning that
nowadays Russia is undergoing kind
of white renaissance,
everything somehow related
to the white movement
[inaudible] values, songs,
literature are extremely
popular in Russia.
There are many drama films and
[inaudible] produced recently
that unlike the abandoned
Soviet narrative [inaudible]
prerevolutionary Russia
and anti-Bolshevik white
movement favorably.
And the reds [inaudible] as radical
fanatics whose main purpose was
destruction of Russia
and its peoples.
I think that the surprising
popularity
of the defeated whites
can be partially explained
by the communist party
efforts to erase the memory
of the white movement
from Russia's history.
However, the 70 years of the
red narrative domination proved
to be counterproductive.
The white interpretations of the
American intervention can be divided
into two sub narratives, the one
created by the supporters of Russian
and -- of Russian anti-Bolshevik
socialist parties
and the one created by
the Russian rightists.
The letter included not only
far right loyalists advocating
restoration of [inaudible] dynasty,
but also [inaudible] conservatives
and nationalists who
oppose the socialists.
One would think that the whites,
who refused to recognize the
Bolshevik treaty with Germany
and continue to fight
on the American side,
should have created a
pro-American narrative.
However, the right whites
unanimously accused their
[inaudible] of provoking
and escalating the Civil War
to win Russia this
[inaudible] people.
Basically, the white
narrative asserted
that not only the United States,
but entire Entente have provoked
the Civil War to force Russia
to continue fighting
against the Germans.
And when they failed to
[inaudible] Russian people,
they [inaudible] treacherously
abandoned them to suffer torture
and death at the hands of
the victorious Red Army.
According to this narrative,
General William Greaves,
the commander of the American
expeditionary force in Siberia,
in fact, gave assistant --
gave assistance not to his white
allies but to the Bolsheviks.
And the [inaudible] had generally
financed antigovernment terrorist
organizations, including
the Bolsheviks,
to destroy the Russian empire.
This narrative often noted in
all kind of conspiracy theories
and knowledge [inaudible]
themselves constitute a fertile soil
for creating conspiracy theories,
not only in contemporary Russia
and the United States but worldwide.
So my research aims at finding
inconsistencies, false premises,
wrong conclusions,
misunderstandings,
and misinterpretations in
this anti-American narratives.
Here at the Library of Congress
I studied archival documents
from 12 collections,
including papers
of President Wilson's
Secretary of State Lansing,
Secretary of War Baker, Senator
William Borah, American Ambassador
to Japan [inaudible],
and many others.
It was priceless to have all the
necessary publications at hand,
especially the recently
published ones.
What surprised me in the
U.S., despite the fact
that this two year-long
occupation of a huge part
of Russia's territory is not known
to the [inaudible]
academia audience,
it has been actually scrutinized
in every single detail.
Also, I discovered that the
library possesses a unique
and very rare collection of the
white authors' writings published
in Europe between the 1920 --
between the 1920's and 1930's.
In conclusion, I would like to
say that my research is not over
and I need to study tons of
materials at the National Archives
in Washington, D.C., as well as
some Russian and Japanese documents.
But anyway, I'm sure that the
information that I collected
at the Library of Congress will
constitute the most important part
of my database.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Chelsea Stieber: Okay, hello.
Thank you everyone for coming.
Thank you also to the Library
of Congress, the Kluge Center
for organizing, and also, yeah,
to all of these wonderful talks.
I'm sorry that I was not
here for the beginning.
I am now back to teaching.
So I'm wearing these two hats.
So I'll start right off so we can
get to questions and then food,
and hopefully both at the same time.
So it was interesting,
I got the poster sent
to me Travis [assumed spelling]
and I thought to myself,
oh no, that's the wrong title.
And I realized that I had proposed
a title in 2015 for what I was going
to be doing at the
Library of Congress,
and it has turned into this.
So this, I think my talk will
hopefully be a testament to the work
and the research I've done here
that has really transformed
and enriched the scope
and rigor of my book.
So, yes, it's changed quite a bit.
So in this talk I'll just do a
short overview of my book project,
focusing on the main
intervention as well as the stakes
in the fields I'm working in, and
then I'll briefly describe two
of the collections that I've used
here to make that work possible.
So as you see, the book
project, it's currently
under the working title Haiti's
Paper War, Post-Independence Writing
and the Making of the
Republic, 1804 to 1954.
And the book basically does --
is what it's doing is
revealing the power struggles
and strategic silences at stake
in the scripted representations
of Haiti's past since 1804.
I'm particularly interested
in questions of civil war
and regional conflict as they
played out almost continuously
in literature, politics, and
culture in postcolonial Haiti.
Indeed, and this is really sort
of really the main crux of this
at the moment, while much recent
scholarship has rightly emphasized
the Haitian revolution as
the radical instantiation
of enlightenment liberalism in the
Atlantic world, it is not only this.
So my book considers the aftermath
of Haiti's radical
anti-colonial gesture within Haiti,
and specifically the
factional conflicts
that both shaped the
revolution itself
and conditioned the possible futures
postcolonial independence statehood.
And a brief background here on the
history and the specificity of this,
because it will be
useful to you, I think.
The newly independent state of Haiti
in 1804 divided itself
along the same lines
that had divided it during the
revolutionary period between those
who were liberals, who wished to see
the independent state as a republic,
and in 1804 they wanted
to proclaim Haiti
as the last true remaining
place of liberal enlightenment,
especially after the first
French republic had faltered.
And then on the other side,
those who envisioned a
military authoritarian regime.
These tensions remained
unresolved for the first two years
of Jean-Jacques Dessalines' rule
over independent Haiti
from 1804 to 1806.
And it's important to note here
that this state never bore
the name of a republic.
It was a military state
and then an empire.
And it was Dessalines'
decision to proclaim an empire,
orchestrated in secret
by his advisors,
the backers of this
military authoritarian state,
that more or less sealed his fate.
The republican faction
staged an uprising
and assassinated Dessalines
in October 1806.
So the republican faction
felled the empire,
but they were unable
to unite the nation.
Instead, Dessalines'
assassination marked the start
of an official civil war between
north and south, between monarchy
and republic, that
lasted until 1820.
And what's so fascinating about this
period to me, and what is so useful
for understanding the rest of
Haitian history in my mind,
is that we see two
drastically different versions
of postcolonial Haitian statehood
play out, vying for hegemony.
These are possible futures
of what an abolitionist black
state could or should be.
And one of the most
salient differences
between the two sides is
the way that each state used
and defined the notion
of, liberty, liberty
or freedom depending on
how you translate it.
And if we take as given that
both regimes, both the monarchy
and the republic, agreed that
liberty did mean abolition
and freedom from chattel
slavery, it is also true
that they fundamentally disagreed
on its meaning with regard
to enlightenment principles and
questions of individual rights.
So did liberty mean
independence from colonial rule
or did it mean freedom
from arbitrary government
and the guaranty of
individual rights?
And this differed in each state.
In the north, Christophe,
Henri Christophe, the king,
saw liberty primarily as
independence from colonial rule
and not as a guarantee
of individual rights.
Indeed, the two for him
were mutually exclusive.
His military state turned
monarchy placed individual,
or rather anti-colonial
independence, above all else.
That meant that individual liberties
and rights had to be sacrificed
for this greater good
of sovereign statehood.
Conversely, Alexandre Pation's state
in the south finally founded the
republican government that partisans
of enlightenment liberalism had
been envisioning since 1791.
His regime embraced the
revolutionary language
of individual rights and radical
democracy, but it is important
to note often felt short --
fell short of this in practice.
So I've elaborated on
these foundational tensions
in early postcolonial Haiti at
length here because I believe them,
as I said before, to be central
to understanding the continued
civil war secessionist regimes
and regional conflicts that
persisted throughout 19th
and 20th century Haiti, and
even to the present day.
And more important for our purposes
here, they reveal crucial background
on the battles over national
identity and cultural legitimacy
that have marked Haitian
writing since independence.
For -- while I place great
importance on historical
and political background here in my
work, my book is ultimately still
about writing and how
we can use writing
to trace the continued
residences of civil war
and regional conflict in Haiti.
Take, for example -- here,
let me check my time.
Yeah, we're good.
[Speaking foreign language] or paper
war that occurred between the north
and south during this 1806
to 1820 civil war period.
The printed matter that came
out of each regime, the monarchy
and the republic, supported their
oppositional political agendas.
So in the north we have
pamphlets, newspapers,
and essays from the
northern monarchy
that served a primarily
utilitarian purpose in support
of the regime's militant
anticolonial agenda.
In the southern republic, on the
other hand, and this is fascinating
to witness, writing begins to
take on the emergent modern sense
of literature as [speaking foreign
language], that is literature
as imaginative, creative works,
of the autonomous liberal mind.
And so southerners were doing this
in order to position themselves
against northern writing and
also to position themselves
within a world republic of letters
that supported their
liberal enlightenment agenda.
They actually did this
via the literary magazine,
which was itself a recent invention
of the republic of letters.
So these southern writers
were performing the successes
of the liberal republican model
by heralding literary writing
as a direct expression
of the liberal mind
and the creative intellectual
abilities of the individual author.
So here the book basically reveals
how writing itself became the
subject -- excuse me?
>> Slides?
>> Chelsea Stieber: Oh no,
no, this is just a preface.
Oh, but thank you very much.
No, no slides yet.
They're at the end.
Yeah, my book basically shows how
writing itself became the subject
of civil war, and more
specifically the limits and criteria
for what constituted literature at
specific moments in Haitian history.
So what I've done and what
I've done with this research is
to basically trace this throughout
the 19th and 20th century
where we see these sort of
returns and continued residences
of these foundational fractures
in writing, and especially
between this idea of a utilitarian
form of writing that was in support
of a certain regime and a much more
liberal [speaking foreign language]
idea of literature.
So ultimately my book is a
new history of Haitian writing
that focuses on civil war,
on internal divisions,
and strategic silences that
have shaped our conception
of Haitian national literature.
The need for new scholarship
that interrogates oversimplified
representations
of Haiti's diverse
realities is a pressing one,
but I think even beyond the
immediate Haitian context my book
offers a compelling regional
paradigm for grappling
with the wider Caribbean, which
like Haiti, remained geographically,
politically, and culturally
stratified for most
of the 19th century and,
of course, into today.
The Dominican Republic
is an excellent example,
divided between north and south,
between interior and coast.
Cuba is markedly different
from west to east.
But because these various Caribbean
populations have been defined
since their inception as sort of --
in relation to the European
metropole, they are marginal
because Europe is center, this
makes them always already regional
in a larger Euro Atlantic context.
So in essence, my book
is challenging the notion
of the Caribbean regional and
the Euro Atlantic and arguing
that regional difference within
the Caribbean is a necessary
and productive lens for analysis.
One final note just
on contributions.
There's some debates in francophone
postcolonial literary studies
about this idea of what was
literature and the world republic
of letters because I think it's
really useful to think here
about what gets obscured
and what gets highlighted.
I'm joining up with some other
scholars who are working on sort
of critiques of the field
to reveal how studies
of Caribbean literature has failed
to consider, or even register,
marginal, and in this
sense I mean non-hegemonic
or non-cosmopolitan writing
precisely because it does not engage
with the market forces of
international recognition
or world literary debates.
So I'm identifying
a culture of writing
from beyond the world republic
of letters on the margins
of this international literary
field of Paris-based consecration.
And one note on methodology and
sources by way of transitioning
to my slides, and also to the
content section of this talk,
to do this book, to focus on
silences, what's written out
or delegitimized in scripted
representations of Haiti,
it was absolutely critical
for me to go back
to primary sources themselves.
So the histories that were written
in the 1850's and the 1890's,
newspapers, essays, rather than
relying on secondary readings
of that original content and
specifically Anglophone readings.
And this is something that
I know is sort of widespread
in everyone's field, but the
need for Haitian studies is so,
so strong because there is this sort
of, not a slippage, but a failure,
I think, to take account of
when there is this tension,
the civil war tension that
I'm talking about that sort
of gets reproduced
throughout the 19th century.
It also involved a lot of reading.
And so, you know, to the extent that
that's possible for a book project,
and I certainly have learned as
this is my first book, what is
and is not possible to take
on, but being able to work here
at the Library of Congress has
been transformative in that way.
The library holds so many
Haitian sources from the 19th
and 20th century, the
most important ones
but also some really interesting,
lesser-known publications
from Haitian scholars produced
locally, many of which exist outside
of this Port-au-Prince sphere as
well which has been fantastic.
So in the final minutes that I
have here I want to highlight two
of the collections
that I've been using
that are really critical
to my research.
So the first is a Haitian
social science journal,
the [speaking foreign language].
It's a social science journal.
It's arguably the most important
20th century social science journal
in Haiti, and it certainly
the most prolific,
and still in existence
today as well.
It's a hugely important
repository of scholarly production
of locally produced
knowledge in Haiti,
and the library has a
near complete run of it.
It's one of the only libraries
that does in microfilm
or on microfilm [inaudible]
and in bound volumes.
I will not belabor
this point; however,
because I already gave
a short talk on it
at the National Digital Initiatives
Collections as Data Conference here
at the library, so you can just
watch it and learn a little bit more
about this so I can
skip to the other stuff.
We're also doing an exciting digital
humanities project with this here
at the library, labs.loc.gov.
So check it out.
It's on my Twitter but I think it's
the sixth hour and 35 minute mark
on the YouTube channel for that
conference so check it out.
Okay, so the second
resource that is --
that I've been using is this
fascinating manuscript division
collection called the
Celestine Bencomo Collection.
The collection holds hundreds of
pieces of archival material related
to nearly every Haitian head of
state from the 19th and early --
all of the 19th and then
the early 20th century.
Just a little bit on this
interesting man, Celestine
or Celestino Bencomo, served as
the Console of the Republic of Cuba
in Port-au-Prince on
and off 1909 and 1914.
And during that time he collected
all sorts of interesting pieces,
lithographs, painted
portraits, decrees, letters,
other official documents on
or about Haiti's leaders.
And he gifted this material to
the U.S. government in 1925,
at which point the Department
of State transferred it
over to the Library of Congress.
And having this fascinating
and really well-preserved
archival material allowed me
to do some fun things, some
new analyses on some rare,
and in some cases, as
far as I know, unique,
historical documents on Haiti.
And so specifically here I did a
few other analyses, but this one is
on the heraldry and coats
of arms of Haitian leaders.
So what I want to kind of show
is how these coats of arms,
this heraldic symbolism, reveals
the ruptures and continuities,
the [inaudible] and
adaptations of symbols of power
in early postcolonial Haiti.
And more specifically, I want to
make an argument about the empire
of Fostou Soluke, you
have his name here,
who is one of Haiti's least
studied or understood leaders.
He ruled as an emperor
between 1849 and 1858.
And there is a black legend that
surrounds the history and legacy
of his rule that is not too
dissimilar from the memory
of Napoleon III in France.
And indeed, the two ruled during
the same period, though it's true
that Soluke proclaimed his
empire before Louis Napoleon.
And in this sort of black
legend Soluke is either a symbol
of violence and cruelty or of
ignorance and pure mimicry.
The truth is, of course, somewhere
in between, or maybe not even there.
But it's true that Soluke's legacy
and memory is heavily mediated
by his detractors' depiction of
him, especially because there's
so little self-representation from
his regime in the way of writing,
artwork, or propaganda, which is
why this Bencomo Collection has
so many original documents
is amazing because we're able
to see some of what the documents
coming from his regime looks
like and some of the images.
And just a side note, Soluke is
best known for Solukery [phonetic],
which were basically French
republican caricatures,
detractors of Napoleon III's
regime who used the image
of a black emperor in Haiti
to ridicule the return
to empire under Louis Napoleon.
And so what I'm trying to
do with these images is sort
of understand more about
this particular leader.
So let's just look
briefly at the images
and I'll do a little comparison just
to show you how I did my reading
and analysis of these coats of arms.
So here you have -- and
what's really fascinating
with the Bencomo Collection is you
have a bunch of different documents,
so I was able to look at the
variation of these coats of arms.
And in fact, you know, for Soluke I
think I found four different ones,
for Christophe there were six.
So it's interesting to see that
there were different printers
and different images, or
not images rather plates
that they were using for these.
So let me show you
the first comparison.
So here we have Napoleon I's coat
of arms, 1805, and Dessalines' coat
of arms just to show you --
what I want to show you is how
Soluke builds his out more or less
from these prior leaders.
What's fascinating, and
these are not actually
in the Bencomo Collection,
unfortunately, although there is --
there are a few documents
from Dessalines, which is --
which is great, even
from [inaudible].
But you see here, there's
a really big difference.
And Dessalines created his
coat of arms after Napoleon I.
There's a little bit
of an interesting thing
going on in history here.
They -- it appears that Desslines
backdated all of his decrees and all
of the official nominations of
him as emperor to make it look
like he nominated himself, or
was nominated before Napoleon,
but it's not true, or that's
what it most likely looks like.
And it's a compelling argument,
I believe that to be the case.
In any case, so we're going on the
idea that Dessalines created his --
oh no, Dessalines created his
coat of arms off of Napoleon I.
But as you see here, there
really isn't that much
that they're working on, right?
There isn't that much that's shared.
We have the lions in Dessalines,
you have the [inaudible],
which is significant in
French revolutionary imagery
but also the importance of
the rooster in Hispaniola
and in the specific [inaudible]
case is also interesting.
So I'll come back so that you can
see some of the other comparisons.
Then we come to Henri
Christophe's coat of arms,
which is a significant departure
from Dessalines but brings some
of the Dessalines image
in and also then starts
to look a little bit more like a
more typical or characteristic,
a more real symbol, perhaps closer
to Napoleon or more generally
to a coat of arms as it would
look in any regime of that sort.
I'll skip over the details
just for the sake of time,
but it's interesting to
remark the different ones
that I was able to find.
And then here you can
see the comparison now
to what Soluke came up with.
And so it's interesting because
Soluke basically, I think,
reinterprets Napoleon I's coat
of arms through Dessalines
and Christophe's adaptations.
So he's creating something
that's wholly derivative
but entirely new at the same time.
He maintains the two lions, and
his lions, I think, look much more
like Christophe's than
like Dessalines,
but the way that they're
turned also evokes Dessalines,
which is really interesting.
He returns the eagle
to the shield instead
of the [speaking foreign language]
that Dessalines had or the phoenix
that Christophe had,
the mythic phoenix.
He also at the liberty tree,
which I think is interesting.
This is a republican, the Haitian
[speaking foreign language]
which is a republican symbol
which leads me to believe
that he's basically amassing
symbols from prior regimes in order
to create a more capacious
idea of his power
and of Haitian national identity.
Interestingly though,
the most radical gesture
in this is his addition
of the imperial rope,
which returns us -- oh, I'll skip.
Yeah, that was Christophe.
You can see some of
those similarities.
And then back to Napoleon I.
I mean, the imperial robe is
an exact replication of --
I mean, he basically just
puts all of that on top
of the Dessalinean [phonetic]
or Christrophean [phonetic]
imagery there.
And he actually used this imperial
rope in his coronation ceremony.
We have images of it.
So they're in the collection.
So it's interesting.
He's -- it's a complete copy
of Napoleon I that's sort
of dressing this interesting
reinterpretation
of previous symbols
of Haitian power.
And so I wonder, by
way of concluding this,
what that might tell
us about Soluke.
And as I said before, I
think it points to his savvy
and an understanding of creating
and using symbols to gesture
to previous Haitian rulers and to
create this larger sort of idea
of Haitian national identity.
But the Napoleon focus,
I mean this is what
so many historians have pointed to,
it was just pure imitation
of Napoleon.
I think there's something certainly
a bit more sophisticated going
on there, not least of all
because in -- on December 20, 1848,
Louis Napoleon, Napoleon
III, was elected president
of the second republic in Haiti.
And so at the very least we have an
awareness of this fact in this sort
of return to imperial
Napoleonic symbolism
and this 1849 heraldic
symbolism from Soluke.
I think, my own interpretation that
I'm still kind of still working
through right now, is that it's
actually a really great form
of sophisticated trolling and
that Soluke actually proceeded
the [inaudible].
I mean he was sort of wanting
that perhaps even to happen.
In any case, I think what we see
from this analysis is a much more
sophisticated and complex portrait
of a little studied and
even less understood leader,
which I was able to undertake.
So I'll leave it there.
Thank you again for listening.
I look forward to the discussion.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible ]
>> John Van Oudenaren: To proceed
but we can both take questions
from the floor and we can also have
the panelists comment to each other.
Either one, I think, would work.
So do any of you want to
comment on each other's work?
>> Chet Van Duzer: A
question for Ascension.
You mentioned the possibility
of descendants
of the singers being
interested in the project,
and I wanted to know whether
that's happened so far?
>> Ascension Mazuela-Anguita:
Yes, that's an excellent question.
We have [inaudible] which
the database is collected.
We have messages from descendants
of the informants asking
about if we have as part
of the collection somebody,
her grandfathers or grandmothers,
and sociologically
it's quite interesting.
>> Chet Van Duzer: That
must be very gratifying.
>> Ascension Mazuela-Anguita:
Yes, it is.
>> John Van Oudenaren: Others?
>> Margarita Karnysheva: Oh,
I have a question to Chet.
Do you think that these
ancient maps can be used
for educating modern students?
>> Chet Van Duzer: Wow, I --
>> Margarita Karnysheva:
Not in geography but --
>> Chet Van Duzer: I'm certainly
finding it very educational going
through the annotations.
So I hope eventually, yes,
that other people will
learn from them as well.
So thank you.
>> John Van Oudenaren: Actually,
I would start out with a
question for Chet as well.
About the annotations, the -- are
they all based on classical sources?
I mean, this is 1525.
By this time you've got, you
know, several decades of Spanish
and Portuguese discoveries,
exploration, is that incorporated
in the annotations or is
it just purely exercising
classical literature?
>> Chet Van Duzer: It's -- so a lot
of classical learning comes by way
of these sort of collections
of classical quotations
that were published in
Italy in early 16th century.
But there's very, very little
reference to recent discoveries.
There's a fair number of
corrections of classical authors,
but not on the basis of Portuguese
or Spanish voyages, for example.
>> John Van Oudenaren: Because at
some point the Europeans conclude
that Ptolemy is an interesting
artifact, but just totally wrong.
I don't know when that occurs but it
can't be too much later than this.
>> Chet Van Duzer: Yes, but not yet.
>> John Van Oudenaren:
Not yet, okay.
Anyway, all right, I was
very curious about that.
Other questions?
Comments?
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
>> About the students.
You mentioned that these -- he
would have written these things
for a student and I wondered what
kind of student would be doing this?
Is it a map making student
or a student of classics
or who would the student be?
>> Chet Van Duzer: So
what I'm imagining is
that the annotator would essentially
tutor for a very wealthy family
in northeastern Italy is
as close as I can get.
And it would have been part
of an education devoted
to both classical literature
and specifically geography,
not map making as such
but geography principally.
>> John Van Oudenaren: Very good.
Okay, well I think it's probably
best maybe if we continue informally
around the food and the wine.
I thank -- these have been
four fascinating talks.
They're on different subjects
but also people coming
out of different sort of, I don't
even want to use the word academic,
different research traditions,
different institutions
that they're working from,
from, you know, our last speaker
who is really grounded in the
American academic tradition it seems
to other, you know, Spanish,
Russian, and Chet, I guess,
is our free flying spirit, whatever.
And so it's been not only different
topics, but also different ways
that people, different
traditions, different methodologies
that people can approach material
and get fascinating results from.
So please join with me
in thanking our group.
And again, this is an experiment
so we really appreciate feedback
on how we proceed in the future.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
visit us at loc.gov.